se trata sin duda de uno de los viajes
más importantes pero también más
controversiales para Black shoulses de
que asumió como canciller alemán un
viaje a China marcado por las muy
fuertes relaciones económicas entre
ambos países entre China y Alemania
china es el principal socio comercial de
Alemania y shorts de hecho viajó
acompañado de una delegación de
empresarios pero también un viaje
marcado por muchas preguntas por muchas
críticas no solamente de parte de
sectores políticos aquí en Alemania que
ven el viaje con escepticismo sino
también de Parte de algunos de los
socios europeos más importantes de
Alemania que han expresado sus críticas
hay preguntas sobre si esa estrecha
relación económica no se está
convirtiendo más bien en una dependencia
riesgosa en especial luego de que el
gabinete Alemania en particular olabsols
aprobaran una inversión china en el
principal Puerto alemán en Hamburgo y
hay preguntas sobre Por qué scholls
viajó solo a China y no acompañado de
otros líderes europeos como el
presidente francés Emmanuel
defendió su viaje explicó la necesidad
de hablar con china en el más alto nivel
explicó que coordinó por adelantado con
sus principales socios Pero estas
preguntas y estas dudas están ayudando a
dar la impresión de que scholls prefiere
un camino individual y no tanto una
solución conjunta a nivel europeo para
los principales desafíos que afectan al
bloque comunitario